some heavy hitters backing joe biden are
in las vegas right now
orca mana joins us live from a voter
mobilization event near russell and fort
apache with more on their efforts
orco
well sasha superstar singer cher is in
las vegas campaigning for joe biden
she's about to take the stage here any
minute now but you can already see
there are a large group of biden harris
supporters
here in this area ready to hear from
share today is early vote day
and that's just part of cher's message
to get nevadans to go out and vote
another big name in town today stumping
for joe biden
is stacy abrams a former candidate for
georgia governor
abrams is also the founder of fair fight
action an organization promoting fair
elections and voting rights
today she's encouraging nevadans to go
vote she attended a voting rights
discussion
and a conversation with black women
about their important role in this
election
i spoke to abrams in a one-on-one
interview and she tells me in order for
progress to happen
all nevadans need to make their voices
heard
it is critical that we have every person
who has the right to vote cast a ballot
and here in nevada doing that will
continue to make change possible
not only in the state but around the
country
as i mentioned share is also in town in
response to these campaign events
the trump team is putting a spin on the
singer's lyrics saying in part quote
joe biden would turn back time to the
days of record unemployment
and home foreclosures nevadans can feel
something inside them
say they really don't think joe biden is
strong enough
again cher is expected to address the
crowd here on stage in just a little bit
early voting is still going on here in
nevada and runs through october 30th
and of course election day is just 10
days away reporting live in las vegas
tonight orcomanna 8 news now